help is someone hurt  what are you hearing sally according to  first responders it was a bomb  how many four of yours and five passes  by has anyone claimed responsibility we  found this do you think she's dead we  can't find her  the bomb has traces of chromium never  seen this since paris the watchmaker  abbott's still alive i understand  i have no choice  is demanding answers i think you tried  to kill him what  sam  no i didn't do any of this  she's an extraordinary asset  and why she's still running  i need to get into the embassy  place is crawling with marines there's  no other way  five files were really big it was  abbott's id  if you get her in your sight do not  hesitate this code name is the  watchmaker he's one of the most wanted  assassins in the world  we don't assume the worst of our best  people when we don't sell them out at  the first sign of trouble  you